Good morning winner
Take a deep breath
Visualize the Mount your success and look down at everyone who's ever
doubted you
Fuck those losers. Fuck them in their stupid fucking faces
Talk to her she's got a really cute smile Amy to knows how many girls are gonna be up your vagina
Not sure every time I come to visit you you're gonna be scissoring and different girls, dude
This ring is not a thing. Don't knock it into benighted. Don't knock it until you've tried it
It's the last day. We got you through high school. I need to go VanDerveer budget numbers, man
We just graduated head off to college. That should do it, right
I can't hear you. I can't soundproof glass
We have to go to a party to me what nobody knows that we are fun
They didn't party because we wanted to focus on school and get into good colleges and it worked
They're responsible people who partied also got into those colleges. I'm incredible at hand jobs, but I also got a 1560 on the SATs
We haven't broken any rules name one person whose life was so much better because they broke a couple of rules awesome
He broke our rules Rosa Parks naman else. Who's in the Anthony?
dammit
Hand sanitizer that traps tic-tac mace listen, it is very important that you keep the safety
What the fuck is this oh my god, can I say
Well, this seems excessive shotgun just kidding I don't have one
Don't see we're having a date night why it's funny your parents think we're boning, but you do have is fashion
We are going to show each other how much we care about each other
Well, probably just do a korean face mask. I don't need to know all the words